hey guys welcome back to the channel and
today we're going to be talking about
the new post that just went up on reddit
today from the Ubisoft community manager
now Ubisoft likes to be kind of open
about what they do on the reddit which
is always a great place which is always
great because it gives me more it gives
me more insight of what's going on and
then it gives you more insight because
and I tell you about these certain
things now what the Ubisoft community
manager stated is that on march six
teams which i believe is today they are
having a routine back-end maintenance i
guess the servers are going [ __ ] again
not that that's new or anything but
they're also having new weekly content
so it says here tomorrow morning we will
prove we will perform a routine
maintenance on our online infrastructure
at eight a.m. eastern standard time for
an estimated downtime of an hour and 45
minutes this maintenance will be back
end only and we will use this time to
update the game with the new weekly
content now before the devs have this
thing called the devs den or the biggest
like the dev den on youtube or on twitch
where the Ubisoft people go on a twitch
stream and talk about the new stuff
they're going to be adding or address
issues of that week for for honor and
they're going to be adding new emotes to
the game for each character which is
also great and at the very bottom he
also stated says yes new content was
shown this week on the Warriors den
stream you will see more of that
tomorrow but indeed there's some very
cool emotes so what I'm taking from this
is that Ubisoft is going to gradually
start adding more stuff every week for
us to enjoy so we can never be out of
content I kind of like this approach
because they gives us more stuff like I
stated before it gives us more of more
stuff more stuff to them play around
with probably more cameras more emos
maybe they're going to start adding new
maps and they're going to add the new
heroes that's the season and it gives us
more stuff so that we can't get bored of
the game the only thing that we could
really sell this game for the connection
issue but I hope that they will
hopefully address this at least at one
point that's all I have for today guys I
hope you did enjoy this very quick video
on the new weekly content lyrics but
they're hopefully going to be adding
if you enjoyed this video please leave a
like and tell me down in the comments
below what other things they could add
for the weekly content whereas I could
be like I said new emotes new maps any
ideas that you guys have throw them down
in the comments bowl I'm always curious
to hear and other than that if you're
new to this video and you're new to the
channel please hit that subscribe button
always putting out before on our content
you know what it is and I really do
enjoy the support on beginning on these
last few videos reaching some good
milestones here guys enough I'll see you
all later and piece of wood